back in the kitchen well I belong
because it is just nice and familiar hey
guys look at me I'm back in the kitchen
and that could mean one of two things
I'm cooking or I forgot that I was
existing in time and space and wandered
into the kitchen who knows which one's
correct today I'm going to make
something that I think is very exciting
I've never made it before and I
conceptualized it last night while I was
sleeping while I was not sleeping I
thought about it I've been trying to
think of party foods that also have some
sort of game element to them so I came
up with a food item that I'm calling
turn oh damn it turn down for what turn
down for what I'm gonna make turnovers
sort of filled with a variety of food
items that my party guests which don't
exist this is just for me they won't
know what's in each turn down the
appetizer thing so turn down for what
turn down for what is actually in it
in hindsight I understand that one of
the joys of food is knowing what's in
the food to avoid allergies or just a
non in enjoyment of the flavors but you
only live once
so if you're gonna go out it may as well
be because your friend accidentally gave
you a deadly food allergy while she was
trying to have a fun party game that
incorporated food let's get started for
these croissant rolls that you used to
make pigs-in-a-blanket what I'm going to
do with them in theory I want to
separate them from each other
and make little triangles and put
something inside of the triangle and
turn it over and then put it in
and let it cook I bought a variety of
gourmet treats mac and cheese chicken
onions pizza rolls
meatballs and tofu oh and I have avocado
they're like fancy upper-class fruit
vegetables first what I'm going to do is
I'm going to cook some of the items of
food that I think need to be cooked
before they go inside the crescent rolls
to get cooked further preheat an oven to
400 425 that's about the same thing
these come for about the same time so
we're going to cook them together
because the Internet's all about
collaboration forcing things together
start go that's happening update this
mac and cheese is also here and it cooks
even faster than this mac and cheese so
you're out this is ready three and a
half minutes
prove it Velveeta you will see loose
white powder and pasta this is necessary
for proper cooking thank you for trying
to warn me packaged but I honestly
wasn't weirded out about it at all go oh
my god there's so much cooking happening
also so you guys know you can put in
anything your heart desires because
cooking is mostly about creativity and
not about the quality of the final
result it's time to put you guys on a
tray together they're shaking hands
you're going on you don't get it both of
you sorry but I'll just cook a bunch of
you cohabitate but don't just on the
first day but meatless meatballs too for
those [ __ ] that don't eat meat hi
former self oh I can cook them on the
stove job you cook meatballs with tomato
sauce
don't you hold on macaroni cheese oh
yeah you said to come Louis as soon as I
start pay attention to another food
group whoa
look I the weirdness sauce get everybody
in the hot tub talk about a real sausage
party sake let's get our mac and cheese
the cheese sauce comes in good thing I
got nothing else to do tonight some date
with a toilet cooking so smooth you
stopped recording but here's a
dramatization of what happened I put
them in the oven I'm tasting one of the
meatballs to make sure it's not poisoned
yeah tastes like it's trying to be
something that's not me turn down for
what okay I'm gonna get my crescent
rolls ready and then I put the tofu in
the refrigerator because sometimes you
just gotta cut your losses and realize
that no one wants that it's my favorite
part
why is an open textbook what toes appeal
map where's the pot is it like opening
up a stoners champagne bottle right nope
oh hey no ah
something really cathartic and rewarding
about that
it's a weird and family there you go
come out friends how was school I don't
care
good job great
it's already at 3:25 so it's that 400
before so let's start making our turn
down for what turn down for what I'm
gonna do separate these got a triangle
I'm gonna take mac and cheese a little
bit on this part here and then I'm gonna
fold it over I'm going to pass on TV you
take a fork go from the edges so that it
goes closed great so it looks like that
great camera angle for you to see that
detail let's put some avocado in now
it's Foley well verb house to me ah that
looks like food a nexus tread sugar now
get a pizza roll is this what ratshit us
now we're gonna put them in the oven for
some time until the outside cooked let's
do it good bye class of 2014
what up step class you work give her
back in the top
you guys look so great on the outside I
can't wait any longer I'm gonna taste
them which one do your step recording
then you missed that I ate this and it
was really delicious
why did you do that to me let's keep
tasting them oh if you stop before I
said this this is the meatball want
pepperoni and cheese moksu just schewe
just now I'm gonna try the avocado this
is the one that could be not good at all
that one's curious not bad
just curious Peter all know who's your
dragon dog oh what a fun game turn down
for what
hey the game's re working middle really
good it's safe to say these are all
really delicious and can be a really fun
game I just tricked myself to make these
for your friends and enemies and enjoy
your next party I don't know
oh yeah the first episode of the podcast
not too deep came out on Monday with my
guest Tyler Oakley and I really really
think it's funny so I really hope that
you listen to it Hannah and I are
hosting the Streamy Awards this Sunday
at 7:30 p.m. Eastern Pacific Standard
Time 7:30 Pacific 10:30 Eastern you can
watch it live at stream East at work
where's this guy book calm have you
pre-ordered your guidebook and entered
the book sweepstakes so you can win the
awesome cool wonderful prizes
oh the t-shirts represent accomplished
it's great so many things guys I'm sorry
I'm really sorry
yeah